okay let's bring in Joseph El Casi he is
the head of the Lebanese press editor
Syndicate he joins me live on the phone
now from Beirut a very warm welcome to
you firstly your response to the latest
deaths of three journalists who've been
covering the conflict on the Lebanese
border with
[Music]
Israel first of all I would like to
express my condolences to al- mayadin uh
Channel and the families and the
families of the
journalists this crime committed by
Israel is not the first one and it's not
going to be the last
one I believe they have declared war on
journalists and media Personnel from day
one
or of Al AA flood
operation and if we are to count the
number of our colleagues who have been
killed in Gaza in occupied Palestine the
total number is now more than 60
journalists without talking about their
families their families who have been
targeted deliberately by Israeli Army
and in
Lebanon
this means that
Israel deliberately targets journalists
and media Personnel in Palestine in
Lebanon and
everywhere everywhere where such people
shed light on the crimes and genocide
and massacres committed against
civilians no doubt that Israel has now
or now feels that um credit to the Arab
journalism and media networks that
covers all these crimes because there is
now a turn in the international public
opinion that's why Israel has escalated
their uh aggression against journalists
making them
targets by missile attacks from
airplanes
this is a crime this is a crime that
amounts
to that can can amount to a war crime
can I ask you what sort of basic Pro
protection sorry to interrupt can I ask
you what sort of basic protections you
as the head of the Lebanese press edit
editor Syndicate would like to see or
expect to see in times of conflict like
this
in such conflicts as you know there are
international
conventions that specifies combating
parties not to Target journalists and
media personnel
and and medical staff such as the Red
Cross the red crescent during military
operations this is uh something that is
agreed on internationally and it's
implemented to a certain extent
expressed and set forth in the Geneva
conventions and its um subsequent
conventions however Israel never
respected such
conventions and this is very serious
matter and we need to raise it to the
United Nations and to the international
criminal court and all intern all
International United Nation uh or
organizations that they need to raise
their voices objecting to such a blatant
violation by the by the Israel
government
second journalists in
Lebanon and as you have as we all know
in Gaza they have taken all
precautionary measures and protection
measures set forth or stipulated by
their best
practices as stipulated also The Intern
Institute for safety of journalist they
wear their helmets and their vests and
their vehicles with with the Press inia
identifying them as media Personnel
however Israel tracked them targeted
them bombarded
them never taking such
considerations this means that it's a
deliberate crime
premeditated in other words is
eliminating eliminating and annihilating
all journalist activities right M Mr El
Casi let me ask you this I wonder if you
now fear that these attacks on
journalists as you've described will
silence will intimidate the hard work
that journalists are doing in covering
this conflict what are your concerns
there y
is isra does this not only to intimidate
but also to kill and eliminate any
journalists who stand in the field of
battle to cover the facts on the ground
the Arab journalism and in Lebanon has
demonstrated courage and
Valor commendable in their
coverage
and and and Israel
is the the amount of upset that is felt
by Israel due to the activities of
Palestinian and Lebanese journalists
have announced today
officially that there is
a Ali is a brilliant um journalist in
the field and they have declared that
this is the next
Target they have deed that that there
will be the next Target after targeting
our colleagues in Al May Aladin Channel
and this is this is very clear to
everyone very obvious because Israel now
started to adopt a new
plan namely namely killing and targeting
these two
journalists in Al mayad Channel and
threatening our colleague sh as if they
are sending a message to the to the
journalist and media
[Music]
Personnel not to under take their duties
and never come close to the battle
Joseph El Casi it's been really
important for us to hear your voice and
all of this Joseph casy head of the
Lebanese press editors Syndicate many
thanks